okay I think we'll get started welcome
everyone
so can you remember the last puzzle that
you solved maybe it was a Rubik's Cube
or a jigsaw puzzle how about this one
anyone figure it out
well it's the title of my talk and I
wanted to start with this because
solving puzzles is a similar mindset to
reverse engineering especially puzzles
that you start with the solution or the
answer to the puzzle and work backwards
to figure out how the pieces fit
together so you would have come in here
expecting reverse engineering a classic
video game you probably would have seen
the reverse and immediately immediately
got it
so we've got reverse and this is
obviously an engineering a classic video
game and did anyone get the last two so
this next one is a game called be
incredible machine or TI m so my name is
Tim kanpur so for as long as I can
remember I've been fascinated by
technology and I've really learned best
by pulling things apart and sometimes
putting them back together again so this
is me point apart an 80s bigtrack
programmable robot does anyone have one
of those I've got one so yeah I pulled
it apart and made it into a better robot
but I also like pulling apart software
to see how it works and there was one my
favorite games actually bio-forge
which we're going to talk about today
that about 20 years ago when I was
17 I started tinkering and clean it
apart and over the years I you know kept
coming back to it and recently I was
looking for a project to you know play
with dotnet core so I figured I'd start
porting all the code that I had written
to dotnet core just to make it
cross-platform so I'm gonna share with
you some of the things I've learned
doing that but where do we start with
reverse engineering so there's no silver
bullet and there's many different
disciplines for reverse engineering
really the only common denominator is a
lot of time but I've already said
reverse engineering is like solving a
puzzle so maybe we can use that as
inspiration so I'm sure you all know how
to solve a jigsaw puzzle so you start by
looking at the image of the puzzle on
the box you know sort the colors or the
features into different groups and then
you would probably start with the edge
pieces start at the border and build it
up completing the different groups so
how can we make these steps a bit more
generic to help us well sorting studying
the image is like researching the target
so that's what we're going to start with
you know learn a little bit about
bio-forge and another way of seen
identifying the colors or features and
sorting them into groups is to identify
the overall structure and instead of
start with the border a little bit more
generic start at the boundaries and
really completing the different color
groups is another way of seen dividing
conquer so this is the steps that we're
going to use so our target is bio-forge
so we'll start with step one we need to
learn a little bit more about bio-forge
so to do that we're going to go back
almost 25 years through videogame
history back to March
in 1995 so this is the award-winning box
art for bio-forge and I've got a copy
here still sealed from 1995 which I paid
way too much for on ebay bio-forge is
really the first game I can remember
where the images on the box were
actually not just artist impressions
they really lived up to what they showed
there's a few couple of things that I
want to note before we continue though
so firstly it is copyright I'm not a
lawyer but I did chat to an IP lawyer in
preparation for this talk and I just
want to say that in giving this talk I'm
not suggesting or encouraging you to
infringe any copyright laws so if you
are reverse engineering anything just be
mindful of the legalities and if you're
unsure have a chat with a lawyer in this
case in this case bio-forge copyright is
owned by Electronic Arts and you can
still buy bio-forge on Good Old Games
it's about eight bucks just another
thing to note by Forge is mature rating
and at the end of this talk there will
be some pixelated blood so if so to
learn a little bit more about bio forge
I've just got some clips here from the
game so it's really a DOS adventure game
where you play a character that has
amnesia you've been abducted and turned
into an cyborg assassin and really the
game is about exploring the planet that
you're stuck on and solving puzzles
using items one of those puzzles I
remember fondly is you have to use a
severed arm to get through a hand
scanner to open a door
and although it was critically acclaimed
it didn't really sell sell that well
this you know could have been because it
was really hard we're demanding so at
the time it used required eight
megabytes of RAM and 486 with 33
megahertz this was before the time
really of hardware graphics acceleration
been commonplace and so by 4G is a
software 3d renderer which meant that it
needed that really high-end hardware one
thing a lot of people don't know if you
if you even if you had played bio-forge
is that it was the first game ever to
use 3d texture mapped characters so this
is pretty commonplace in every game
these days and it started with bio-forge
so the developers were very pioneering
so this is a another cyborg that to
battle
it really has diverse you know
environments but to cope with the
hardware they couldn't make all this 3d
so you're dealing with fixed camera
angles and pre-rendered environments so
if anyone played the game
has anyone played the game no so this
this scene here is one of the most
frustrating puzzles you have to get at
the time in exactly right so now that we
know a little bit about the game we're
going to move on to step two so
identifying the overall structure of the
game and to do that all we're going to
do is just have a little bit of look
through the the files in the game and
this is really my first tip if you want
to prevent your software from being
reverse engineer is don't you know
deploy the artifacts with such good
names in in really well named folders
because that's like you know already
having the colors of the puzzle
pre-sorted so you can see here we got
some directories this one contains
presumably files to do with the
character 3d character models in here
we've got some files at Indian the
extension FNT so they're probably fonts
we got if you played the game you would
realize that these are the names of the
different levels so we got some level
files all the different items 3d items
that you can pick up in the game there's
different dialogues in the game so these
are all have the extension dot cam and
under music we've got a music FLX then
we got rooms that also have the
extension cam then interestingly we've
got a hundred and twenty-six odd scripts
that are actually quite quite readable
so that all the game logic is in there
and then we have an intro in game SH Oh
file and finally we got sounds so
presumably this is English samples FL X
so another way we can look at the files
in the game is if you fire up like
windows subsystem for Linux or a Linux
box the file command in Linux is really
helpful so I'm going to run this the
file command on all of those files and
see what we get
so most of this is either false
positives or you know not very helpful
but it does pick up one file so saying
these dot SH o files or FLC animations
so this is an autodesk animator format
back in the day and it's giving us quite
a lot of information so this is really
helpful we can see if see if we can open
these up in VLC
so there we go we can already play some
of the movies from the game it's a
little bit glitchy VLC reader for this
format isn't the best but that's all
right
the FLC format has a documented
specification so we can write a reader
from that specification okay so after
looking through the files this is kind
of what we've worked out we've got all
these different formats and you might be
tempted to say well we're reverse
engineering a piece of software why
don't we just disassemble the executable
which I've done and I ended up with a
quarter of a million lines of assembly
but then I thought about it a bit more
and from the research we've done we know
that why Ford uses a software 3d
renderer which would be a substantial
amount of that code but we don't need
the software 3d renderer anymore we have
hardware accelerated graphics libraries
and all of the game logic is contained
in those scripts the SCP files so really
just assembly in the executable is not
going to give us that much obviously
we've got limited time today we've got
half an hour or so to try and reverse
engineer and recreate this game so we're
going to go with step three and start at
the boundaries so we've already seen
that we've got the SH Oh movies albeit
without any music or sound they're
silent and we're going to focus on
recreating the intro and title sequence
to the game to do that we need at least
these six formats so we already have the
the movies so let's move on to the fonts
so we're going to spend most of our time
here
because the the tools and techniques
that I use on the fonts is really
exactly the same as the other formats so
where do we start or you might have
noticed that those four steps were
really recursive so when you're dividing
conquer you can go back to step one and
research and so on and so forth
so let's research a little bit about
fonts so I haven't included all of the
exhaustive research that you might do
here but the things that are key so in
bio-forge the fonts are used for
subtitles and menus and credits and it's
likely given the age of the game that
the fonts will be bitmap fonts rather
than vector based fonts so a bitmap font
you'll need a matrix of pixels with a
given height and width and also original
IBM pcs used extended ASCII code page
437 which is 8 bits for 256 characters
by Ford was multilingual so English
French and Germans they needed to use
some of that extended ASCII but also as
with any ASCII the first 32 characters
are often non-printable so that will be
key so against better advice I'm going
to do a live demo with a hex editor
sorry if this makes you squeamish but
I'll hopefully be able to break it down
for you
so we've researched the fonts so that
was step one step two is identify the
overall structure so good way to do that
is if you look over here at the mini-map
so just bring up a pen so I can
highlight this stuff
so if you look over here you can see
there's clear sections here in the file
where the data structure changes so if
we jump down to that first section and
have a look at where it starts so we can
see it's around for 100 B for 109 or for
100 a in hex so if we move on step 3 now
which is start at the boundaries we'll
jump back to the top the file if we have
a look from the start I've got some some
numbers here that we don't know what
they mean yet but then we find something
that looks interesting to got here a 4-1
a in little-endian so the white order is
reversed so that's actually what we just
saw as the start of that next section so
this must be an offset to that first
section in the file so if we we keep
scanning along so we've got a 4 byte
offset there now it looks like we've got
3 D and then 4 5 7 if your hex
calculations or any good you would have
noticed that for one a plus 3 D is 4 5 7
so this must be like a size and then
we've got another offset so we've got an
offset a size and an offset and this
actually continues
so we've got offsets and sizes and if
you keep continuing that down you find
that there's actually a hundred and
seventy four offsets and sizes and that
that number there AE is 174 so it looks
like we've got a bit of a header here
where it's telling us the number of
offsets and sizes which immediately
follow so if we jump back down to four
one a four one eight and we select that
three D number of bytes am I going to
copy that as a hex string and paste it
into a new file just make sure it's
uppercase and in word wrap on so it
makes sense if this is meant to be a
font that this is a character in that
font the first character so we can
actually restart those four steps again
we don't need to do any more research
but if we look at the overall structure
of this data we can see that there seems
to be sort of three sections here so
we've got all these ones at the end so
let's flip those off and then you might
notice that there's these Deek remit
numbers decrementing by one so let's
split those off so there seems to be
three sections here so
some sort of header to the character and
then if you look at these they seem like
some kind of offset maybe a relative
offset because the numbers are so small
but this doesn't look like a character
at all who looks like nonsense data so
it's a little bit of a bust but remember
from our our research on fonts that it's
most likely that you know the the font
file is using the fonts stored in like
an ASCII order in the file and we know
that the first 32 characters in the
ASCII table often non-printable so that
kind of meshes with what we just found
that first character was nonsense so if
they are stored in ASCII order if we
pick a character that might be make it
easier for us to see a pattern that
might help so I picked capital H because
it has some vertical and horizontal
structure that will make it easier to
spot so this is decimal 72 so let's jump
back and open up our calculator so if we
have our offset table has four byte
offsets followed by two bite sizes so
each item in that table is six bytes so
we say 72 times six but we also had six
bytes preceding that table so we'll just
add another six so this gives us one be
six for what should be the offset for
for the capital H so let's go to one be
six
okay so if our Theory's correct this
should be the offset within the file to
a capital H and this should be the size
of the data for the H so let's go to
remember it's little onion so 20 f7 and
we'll select the size and we'll copy
that to a hex string put it in a new
file just make sure it's all uppercase
turn on word wrap alright so we didn't
go totally bust on that first character
we learnt that the characters seem to
have three sections to them so let's
split that this up into those three
sections
so we've got 75 for so this is a three
section for what should be a capital H
and we're saying before that these look
like relative offsets so relative just
means not absolute within the file so
this 28 actually points to the start of
this section and then the 27 is one byte
in from that and then we've got 26
another byte in from that and so on and
so forth so if we split this data up
based on those relative offsets we end
up with something like this
actually not selected all of the data so
let's just do that again
I can go away
I'm just gonna
all right let's get back to where we
were
so we split the data up based on those
relative offsets it's anyone start to
see any kind of pattern it'll be a
revelation so I'm expecting a cheer once
this is done
okay so anyone see what we're expecting
maybe it helps if a so we were expecting
a capital H and it looks like that's
what we have a little looks a little bit
skew if there are some other numbers in
here that have some meaning so we can
see that these offsets are really the
number of rows so we can actually see up
here in this header that it's tynus that
the it's giving us a width you can see
every row has numbers that add up to
eight and it's also giving us a height
so the number of rows so as I said the
numbers in each row add up to eight so
we must have eight pixels width and if
you if you look at these numbers you can
see that every FD is preceded by a
number that is the number of F DS
following so that's really just telling
us the number of pixels that is
following and then there's other numbers
preceding that and if you think about it
they're really just number of pixels to
skip because this is this is four so if
we spaced that out so it's four pixels
then our H is really lined up so on so
forth so it looks like we've figured out
how to read the the font files so this
is a simplistic overview of what we just
found so we found we had a font header
we had the offset tables for the
character records followed by all the
characters in ASCII order and each
character we found had those three
sections the character info followed by
row offsets and then each row of the
character and we found that many
algorithm with the skip count followed
by the number of pixels and the pixels
themselves one thing to mention is that
you might have noted there's a bit of
redundancy here so if it's telling us
the number of pixels that follow then
there's really no need for it to have
all of those pixels it could have just
said you know 8f DS so this is what's
called run length encoding so they could
have compressed the font files if they
used run length encoding that's that
will come handy with in handy with one
of the other formats so that's the
simple overview of what we found with
the fonts so let's have a quick look at
some code so I've got a font reader here
it's really just using a binary reader
and it's very simple we're just going
through reading in the different bias
that we found whether it's a short so
two bytes or an integer which is four
bytes so it turns out that those first
two shorts in at the top of the font
file where the maximum height and the
maximum width of all of the characters
in the file
so we're reading those in here and then
we remember we had that third short
which turned out to be the number of
characters are the number of offsets in
that table so we're reading that in here
and because we're going to be using
OpenGL 2 to render everything we're
going to basically represent the font as
a texture Atlas so it's basically just
an image with all of the font characters
and their pixels so then we use that
offset table to jump to the first
character and we loop through each
character and there there was some data
in there that doesn't seem to be useful
to us but we did see that that header
for each character had the width and the
height of the character so we'll use
that and then we used those relative
offsets to jump to the the rows for the
character and then we'll loop through
those rows and this is that little
algorithm that we discovered so there
was a number of pixels to skip we'll
read that in here and skip over those
pixels then we read how many pixels are
following followed by the pixel itself
so we read that into the texture atlas
so I've got a little demo here that will
run so this demo is really just dumping
out the texture Atlas to an image just
so we can see so you can see there we've
read in one of the fonts but they were a
number of fonts so let's just try one of
the other fonts to make sure that it's
the same so that was 0.5 we'll try try
another one
there you go if you're paying attention
in the video clips of the game this was
actually the font used for the subtitles
okay so now we've figured out the font
file format and everything else gets
easier from here on out because all of
those techniques or all that you need to
know for the other formats so we'll move
on to those two FLX files that we saw so
they were helpfully named music and isse
ampuls flx
so back to our four steps first thing we
do is research our target so bio-forge
has both music and sound effects and
hopefully the install guide for
bio-forge actually tells us that the
music is general MIDI and the standard
for digital audio is really pulse coded
pulse code modulation so that's a fancy
way of saying you know sampling the
waveform at a uniform rate and
quantizing those samples into commonly
an 8-bit or 16-bit number and it's it's
usually they're signed or unsigned and
there's a range of common frequencies
for PCM so I am just compressing all the
research that I did into the key bits of
information that we need to be able to
reverse-engineer the sounds and the
music so I'm not going to do the hex for
this one because it's really actually
even easier than the fonts so did
exactly the same approach look
the mini-map in the hex editor to look
at the overall structure determine where
the offsets are and this one turns out
to just be like a container file so a
lot like a zip file but uncompressed and
the items within the container really
just MIDI MIDI files or raw PCM audio so
let's have a look first of all at the
music actually will so I've got a common
common reader here for the FLX file it's
a flex reader you'll see a lot of
similarities with the font reader so
I've got a bit of a header here it's a
bit larger than the fonts it's got some
comments and things like that and then
it just has an offset table similar to
the font to be able to locate each of
the items essentially files within the
container and to read out each item it's
just jump into that offset and spitting
out that byte array and then all we need
is the the MIDI files are actually
extended MIDI so just got a converter to
be able to convert from extended MIDI to
MIDI because MIDI is more commonly
supported so let's have a look at the
music demo so for this one really just
using that flex reader to open the file
and loop through all of the items within
the the Flex file and spit them out as
MIDI files to disk so let's run that
and have a listen so if you played by
Ford you would recognize this tune
although it sounds a little bit
different to the game because we're
actually just using the general midi
soundfont that's included by default
with Windows so it does sound a little
bit different so let's go on to the
sound which a little bit more
interesting so recall from the research
that with the sounds it was raw PCM and
there was you know it could be 8-bit
16-bit signed unsigned and a range of
common frequencies so I could have
analyzed the data and tried to work that
out but because the number of
combinations is so small I literally
just brute forced it and went through
all the different combinations until I
could see that I had the right one so
we'll do I'll show you what it sounds
like first and then I'll go through what
it might sound like as I was working
through those combinations so again I'm
just dumping out the the sound to in
this case a web a WAV file so there's a
718 sound effects so there's a
interesting one a log book
this is a rain drop ship Roenick to
control so that's how it is supposed to
sound but if we have a look at this roar
to wave converter so this is really just
writing out a wave file the actual data
is dumped straight out all this is just
the wave header so as I was going
through the different combinations so
we'll say change the frequency and see
what happens
little Rory dropship water to control so
you can sound see that it's not not
right and similarly if originally I
didn't realize what sign the bytes were
so I've got something a bit like this
so you can still hear the the audio
there but it's not quite right so that
was really the only difference with this
format we're just using that brute force
approach to go through those different
combinations to get the the sound
effects correct
okay so we've now got the movies we've
got the fonts got the sound we've got
the music so next is the the cameras
now the word cameras may not make sense
to you just yet so I'll show you a few
examples so I I mentioned it during the
the clip that I was playing but due to
the limitation hardware limitations they
couldn't do a 3d world so instead they
created the 3d world and then
pre-rendered different fixed camera
angles to just 2d images although they
did make the images animated it's a
couple of examples here with the
equivalent pre-production image so our
research for the cameras is that they're
really a bit like a layered gif file so
they can have a number of different
animations in different layers so we
know from looking at the game that it's
most likely VGA mode 13 hex which is 3
20 by 200 256 colors and again just an
images matrix of pixels we're gonna have
a red green blue in the pixel 1 byte for
each of those likely to be some kind of
color palette and I mentioned when I was
doing the fonts about run length
encoding so it's really
basic form of compression for four
images so if there is any kind of
compression it's likely to be run length
encoding so again I'm not going to go
through the hex because it's very
similar to the the fonts and actually
turns out although the cameras have the
extension cam they turn out to just be
the FL X or flex container format which
we found with the the music and the
sounds so within the Flex container it
has the different layers for the images
and I've figured out that the first item
in the container is actually a color
palette because I noticed across all of
the files the first item was always 768
bytes and recall I said that it's 256
colors so RGB 256 colors is 768 bytes so
I figured that must be a color palette
and then each layer of the image again
just splitting it out dividing and
conquering fairly very similar layout
again with a header off sets and each
offset has a different frame within the
layer so really just like a gif one
thing that helped here was recall that I
wrote a viewer for or a reader for the
sh o files the movie files so because
that was a format from the time they
really use similar concepts and ideas
for storing images animated images at
that so writing that reader for the shof
format really helped to understand this
format as well so let's have a look at a
demo for the camera files so this one's
a little bit more interesting
so we've got a camera reader here
so we're reading in that structure
similarly to the the fonts again we got
with tight frame count in the header for
each layer but let me just jump down to
where we actually read in the the pixels
of the images you can see here that they
actually switch between using compressed
and uncompressed per row of the image so
if you think about run length encoding
it actually makes the size larger if the
pixels are always changing frequently
because you're essentially having two
bytes the number of pixels following so
depending on how uniform the pixels are
in your row it makes sense to use run
length encoding or not so they actually
change that from row to row in the image
so if if it is compressed run length
encoding then we read the number of
pixels that are going to follow and then
just repeat that that number of times
and if it's not run length encoding then
within the loop we just read every pixel
so
[Music]
within the demo here I've got we're
first just going to dump out all of the
the layers and frames within one of the
the cam files I've selected an
interesting one here beach B which
you'll recognize so let's run that so
you can see really just got all these
pieces of an image different layers of
the image and frames of an animation so
looking at those images we can actually
form a composite image and actually
output it as a gift
so there we go who have recreated that
part that we saw from the actual in-game
clip all right almost there so about the
movies we've got the fonts about the
sounds and the music that the cameras so
now we just need to glue it all together
and we need some of the scripts to do
that at least so let's have a look at
the scripts so my next tip for making
your own software harder to
reverse-engineer is don't put your
comments into your production artifacts
so all these scripts actually actually
have comments spread throughout them and
the the scripts themselves are partially
compiled they are human readable
somewhat but the comments are definitely
human readable and I actually had to
censor this one another interesting
comment here is this one I kept on
mentioning the hardware limitations at
the time and they had to change the
speed of the movie so that the sound
effects and the music could keep up on
double speed cd-rom drives so that's the
era that we're dealing with alright so
if we have a look at this because we're
trying to recreate the intro and title
sequence to bio-forge so I've opened up
the script helpfully named intro and
looking through this we can see a lot of
things that line up with the intro if
you've watched it and recall that I said
that the movies were didn't have any
sound or music associated with them
so I actually needed scripts to
synchronize the sounds and the music
with the silent animations so you can
see here that really they've got timings
of the animations and this can only be
some kind of synchronization with the
sound effects and music now I'm using
notepad plus plus here because I
couldn't work out how to do this in
Visual Studio code but it's more helpful
if you look at the hex codes for the non
readable characters so we can quickly
determine by looking at the different
scripts that these are commands for
player sound effect or play music and
then these ones there are some other
files in with the scripts with the
extension dot def which are really just
and a big enumeration of all of the
sound effects and the music and with a
little bit of brute force I was able to
figure out that these are really just
indexes into those enumerations it's
using like XS 128 representation for the
the numbers so given all of that I was
able to put together a bit of code that
you know played the sound effects and
the music at the right times in the
animation
[Music]
we've got Bo forged
so by forged I've as I said use dotnet
core with OpenGL for the graphics and F
mod Sam library to keep everything nice
and cross-platform we've already seen
all of the the readers really so all
that's left is to play it
we we should change our signed yeah so
we'll switch that back so another way
you can tell I'm not cheating is again
all of the sound effects are using the
windows default sound font so the music
does sound a little bit different to the
actual game 3q
sh o intro animation synchronized with
the sound effects voices you can hear
and the music in the background all put
together using scripts
[Music]
and soon we'll get up to the scene that
actually has to slow down because of
double speed cd-rom drives I had to also
slow it down to make sure all the script
synchronization is and remember my
warning there is some pixelated blood
there's a fella said interested in
playing the game I believe in using
DOSBox is in the top 100 games dos games
that you should you should play caught
it according to the Internet see they
look way now if you this is the scene
that I actually had to slow it down so I
always thought that they slowed it down
to make it feel dreamlike until I read
that comment in the scripts
[Applause]
so that's the intro sequence but we also
[Music]
do finishes we also were able to
recreate the title screen so the hand
here is a dot cam file it's one of those
and the background is a doc cam file and
the buttons are doc cam files with
animations for the mouse over and we
have you know the the beautiful font
that we reverse engineer so we've only
really touched the tip of the iceberg
here so if you're interested in learning
more you can follow me on twitter i'll
be tweeting once i've uploaded all the
code onto to github including the rest
of the game we'll be doing it in time
for the 25th anniversary of bio-forge
which is March next year or if you want
to have a chat about any of your reverse
engineering projects or the outside
afterwards thank
[Applause]